bis heute mein name flüge nicht
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video arbeit immer wieder zum internet
unterwegs und habe dort einen beitrag
gesehen von der bildzeitung namen vivant
gestört bist du wirklich hätte deinen
inneren morgen dieser beitrag mit in der
kategorie hort auf dem net oder unter
anderem worüber wir lachen weinen uns
ärgern
ja aber kategorien fall liebe bild
zeitung und herren findet sich dieses
bild hier von morgen und darunter steht
nach aufwand habe perfektionistisch wie
morgen aus der gleichnamigen kultserie
macht den teig die redet ja schon einige
werden wir werden heute einen selbst
zusammen machen und zwar in diesem
fenster um herauszufinden wie
perfektionistisch mann ist es dass der
finne werbung wie wiki denn auch erste
damen- herren- dass der bank ein video
für euch geräten gta view mitmacht
hochladen haben wir aufgenommen auch
alles klappt war die datei danach kaputt
und ich habe auch keine zeit man das
dann irgendwie zu berichtigen und 25 mir
leid falls die kameraperspektiven
ungewohnt ist aber das sieht gerade alle
so aus also die kamera steht dort oben
auf einem rechnungswesen buch auch zwei
karton weil ich meinen stativ zu hause
wieder vergessen habe
du sagst ich bin eben perfekten bis
seine freunde sagen du bist wand gestört
und praktisch kann nicht mal mit
minimalen fehlern leben wenn sie so
offensichtlich bin ich da einfach aus
dem weg räumen lassen
deine freunde sagen entspann dich mal
sind doch schon alles zu 90 prozent
perfekt macht schon das eine prozent
du sagst bin ungelogen wirklich editha
auf dem kleinen putzfimmel sag ich mal
scheißegal wenn ich irgendwie bei einem
freund wird unterliegt gegen deine
wäsche home oder irgendwo noch ein
papier platz oder hier in meinem zimmer
sind komplett egal wenn ich allerdings
in meiner eigenen wohnung in köln bin
und ich weiß wo katie sind jetzt gerade
irgendwie weiß nicht vordringen schön
bist ihren freunden freunden was kopf
oder so und wir wollen nachher doch
irgendwo hingehen räume ich halt erstmal
wirklich alle weg weil ich keinen bock
hätte meine wohnung ich habe keinen bock
das leider nicht wie das bier steht oder
stimmt und dass damit alle weiter und so
fort wenn man investiere hombach bekannt
was die junge frauen experimentieren
gern dein weg für diese selbst
anzuschauen die perfekten ist und auch
wir selbst einstellungen neigen könnte
ist aber hey alles hat auch seine
vorteile man braucht weil für diesen
test adleraugen also tief in deiner
inneren morgen welcher dieser kreise ist
anders also ich würde ganz klar sagen
der klink weil man wieder der ist link
verbinden fall näher dran geneigt ein
break und der mitunter auch als auf
jeden fall der kreitling und welcher elf
hier anders auf jeden fall der in der
mitte weil er einfach kleiner ist
also ich weiß ja betrifft die ganze zeit
so bescheuert ist aber mit harris
relativ daraufhin auch wirklich
fernsteuerungen habe ich jetzt einfach
mal dienen der mitte an und jetzt haben
wir hier welche dreieck ist nicht wie
die anderen auch das in der mitte es ist
halt wie er das gleiche bild wie im bild
zeitung es ist dumm
die fed macht keinen sinn ich könnte
ihnen in der mitte an und das wird es
auch dass die ganze zeit die bewegen
sich irgendwie verschiedene versucht hat
sich anscheinend wie andere papiere aber
nicht dazu gedacht in diesem bild hier
abgelenkt und welche kann hier auf der
reihe wieder in der mitte das wir müssen
weiter
oben bleiben das wird einfach weiter
unten ich dachte echt so kranke täter um
zu schauen ob ich wirklich so über
störungen habe perfektionistisch wird
aber es ist ja echt schick einer dieser
punkte irgendwie anders der linken weil
er blatter ist bild wer von euch dunkle
zwar diesen test gemacht dass krieg
keine kinder jetzt meinen ganz links
hier an
jetzt haben wir uns ins feuer verdammter
ernst gibt es irgend jemanden der diesen
test nicht hinkriegt diese sind alle
auch die höhe und das jetzt einfach
nicht auf dieser höhe
leute ich verlinke euch den clip an der
video beschreibung die könnten ja auch
gerne machen aber doch einfach nur noch
ganz rechts an das rechteck mit diesem
hier das hier ein bisschen höher als die
anderen es wichtig dass ermittler an
welche die grünen punkte an das
definitiv der hier weil ein bisschen
weiter auf der antrag und welcher
liefern
ich würde sagen es ist schwierig das mit
limotive kulturen hier ein paar sekunden
später ich würde da wäre hütte bei der
musik leider hat die anderen haben hier
schon die zehnte frage alle identisch
oder etwa nicht
nein wer hier nicht erwarten mich ein
bisschen weiter aus und 11 ok und welche
viereck springt hier auch der reihe
definitiv dabei für dateien fällt und
wir haben als ergebnis katie entgeht
aber auch nicht
ich habe alles richtig wo hat die
universiade augen den text
empfindlichkeiten unebenheiten und jahr
verdammte mussten nun mal sofort
ausbügeln es ist aber auch deine große
gabe den autoren sichere gespür für
details und einen noch so kleinen dingen
mehr qualität verleihen machen die
verrechneten nutze dafür deinen job in
der freizeit wird aber auch mal eine
kleine pause gönnen auch eine orgel euro
ich würde diese enthält nicht als
perfektionisten bis jedenfalls lange
störungen ted bezeichnet sondern einfach
ein augen fällt bzw sowie rechnet ich
meine dass jedes kleine kind hätte das
hinbekommen die bild zeitung erfahren
die auf dem video heute meine damen und
herren ich möchte die ganze sache waren
und zwar gibt es ab freitag also ab
morgen und liebe schwarzen pop star
justin bieber sowie und hier weht schon
dass ich jetzt bei diesen luca mir
schock und die einsendungen oben immer
in die werbe video stehen habe weiß ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das auch
kennzeichnen muss wenn ich einfach
meinen eigenen schock weil sie werbung
machen ich bekomme ich für kein geld
aber ignoriert ist einfach ich hoffe
euch das video irgendwie gefallen
bald mit den kürzeren heutige video aber
ich habe hier wirklich wie gesagt mein
buch stehen eine kamera fiel auch noch
einem rechnungsbuch ich an einer woche
meine letzte klausur deswegen muss ich
einfach lernen lernen lernen lernen
lernen ich habe mich trotzdem
unterhalten können folgt mir bei
instagram ich halten dort laser luca
weil ich täglich abends immer man von
primacom ihren ich ein bisschen lernen
paar fragen beantworten haben ein paar
insider entwickelt im live stream also
folgt auf jeden fall hin zu verfassen
hier findet ihr die eingebildete wenn
ihr darauf klickt könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren es gekocht wird würde mich
sehr freuen
da fast keine videos mehr dann findet
ihr oben allem eingeblendet und hier
findet hier irgendein weiteres video
verlinkt wo ihr euch das jetzt auch mal
anfangen landen weiter freundlich